- So y'all have a lot
of fun as the judges.
So what's going on right here, though?
This is pretty special, right here.
Let's,
get it, get it.
Look at the steps, the around the...
- Yeah, I'm good. Look at that. Turny.
- That's a word
- You know, I just want to say
that I'm making it look effortless,
but a lot of work goes into that.
- I'm aware.
- Heidi, my best friend, Heidi,
is always...
She doesn't sit still,
she's got the energy
of a 5 year old.
And I was commenting on the fact that
I can't imagine what it's like
to walk in heels.
She goes, "Try these on."
I go, "How can I?"
It turns out that Heidi
Klum has huge feet.
- Well she's tall.
- So you know what that means.
(laughing)
- Anyway,
but anyway, she said, "Try these on
and I'll show you how
to be a runway model."
And how can you say no to Heidi Klum.
So I got to tell you, it's not one of my
proudest moments, but it
is forever on video tape.
And you're showing it.
Thank God I'm married.
I'm not in the dating scene any longer.
And if I was, this little
clip will get me out of it.
- Or you never know might show up
or swipe right or whatever
way you're suppose to swipe.
I don't know which way
you're suppose to swipe.